salut romain bonne année ça va toi ah
ouais quand même
il était sûr de toutes les tenir ah bah
non mais au moins je les ai prises un
peu comme le loup du bois
[Musique]
en début d'année il ya deux types de
personnes celles qui décident de prendre
des bonnes résolutions et celle
comprennent pas et dans cette deuxième
catégorie il ya aussi deux genres de
personnes celles qu'on prenne pas parce
que l ont pas envie pas besoin ok et
celle qu'on prenne pas parce qu'elle se
dise que de toute façon les bonnes
résolutions
on les tient jamais et bien cette vidéo
s'adresse à la première catégorie de
personnes est à cette deuxième sous
catégorie de la deuxième catégorie de
personnes un peu complexe maintenant on
va dire ça autrement en début d'année
pour repartir d'un bon pied et parce
qu'on a dû user d'un peu tout pendant
les fêtes on est souvent tenté de
prendre des bonnes résolutions
concernant sa santé
eh ben pour vous donner un maximum de
chances de les tenir je vous propose
quelques petits trucs qui devra bien
vous aider et en fin de vidéo
les règles d'or pour vous donner un
maximum de chances de réussite
arrêter de fumer bon on est d'accord que
c'est une des résolutions les plus
fréquentes et si c'est aussi fréquent
c'est parce que c'est pas facile hein
sinon il y aurait plus tu meurs et du
coup ils trouveraient d'autres
résolutions à prendre
c'est compliqué parce qu'il faut se
passer à la fois d'une substance la
nicotine et d'une vraie habitudes de vie
fumée pour la première il ya les
substituts nicotiniques qui sont pour la
plupart remboursé à 65% par la sécu si
vous avez une ordonnance ça peut être
des patchs des chewing gum des
inhalateurs sans fumée des comprimés
desprès bucco etc
l'idée s'est trouvé ce qui vous
conviennent parce que le cas de chaque
personne est différent et je dis ce qui
vous conviennent parce que c'est plus
efficace dont combiner plusieurs le
patch par exemple il diffuse toujours la
même quantité de nicotine mais en cas
d'envié violente vous pouvez prendre un
truc à réaction rapide genre un chewing
gum un inhalateur etc
par contre la cigarette électronique
elle est pas remboursés par la sécu
alors il ya certaines mutuelles qui la
prennent en charge mais avec un certain
plafond
dames une des raisons pour lesquelles
c'est aussi difficile d'arrêter de fumer
c'est parce qu'il n'ya pas une bonne
technique il y en a autant qui a deux
fumeurs donc ce qui est pas mal c'est de
se faire aider on noie au début par
quelqu'un dont c'est le métier
un tabacologue en cabinet une
consultation anti-tabac à l'hôpital il
ya forcément pas trop loin de chez vous
un pro qui va vous aider à arrêter en
trouvant la meilleure méthode celle qui
vous convient à vous le problème c'est
que ces gens là bon bah ils vous aident
à mettre la machine en marche vous
suivent
mais il ya des trucs qui arrive souvent
quand ils sont pas là genre la grosse
envie qui risque de vous faire craquer
la baisse de motivation etc
dans ces cas là un autre truc qui peut
bien aidé c'est les applis celles qui
répondent à vos questions qui vous
trouvent des sources de motivation qui
vous félicite qui vous disent depuis
combien de temps vous tenez combien
d'argent vous avez économisé quelle
espérance de vie vous avez gagné il y en
a même qui propose des mini jeux vidéo
pour penser à autre chose quand vous
avez une grosse grosse envie de fumer
alors je vais pas vous en recommander
une en particulier je vous laisse
chercher celle qui vous convient pas
vous mais je vous mets quand même
quelques liens dans la description pour
ça et pour tout le reste allez jeter un
oeil
et si vous êtes plus ambiance papier il
ya plein de bouquins sur la question le
plus célèbre est celui d'al hennequart
mais là encore je vous laisse chercher
celui qui vous parle avouent après un
des trucs qui font peur quand on veut
arrêter de fumer c'est de prendre du
poids
c'est pour ça qu'on va enchaîner
directement avec père du sport
là c'est pareil je suis sûr que vous
n'êtes pas mal à avoir ce beau projet
vous mettre au sport où vous y remettre
mon premier conseil bas ce serait
d'aller jeter un oeil à la vidéo sur le
sujet celui où je donne des conseils
pour éviter de se faire mal bah oui
parce que c'est ça le premier problème
surtout quand on sait pas trop comment
s'y prendre du coup là c'est pareil
c'est pas mal de se faire guider un peu
surtout au début
histoire de voir ce qui vous convient le
mieux en fonction des résultats de vous
voulez atteindre et du coup de faire un
petit programme pour ça plusieurs
options
un coach en chair et en muscles à
domicile ou en salle si vous êtes
inscrits ou une appli ou les deux pour
les applis vous avez l'embarras du choix
mais en gros il ya celles qui mesurent
vos performances pour le rni
le vélo par exemple celles qui proposent
des programmes de fitness ou de
renforcement musculaire tout près ou
modulable et celles qui vous propose de
trouver des cours pas loin de chez vous
là encore à vous de trouver ce qui vous
convient le mieux mais je vous mets
quand même quelques liens dans la
description si rien de tout ça vous
convient si vous préférez rester tout
seul chez vous mais quand même faire du
sport bien sûr il ya les chaînes youtube
et si vous décidez de vous y mettre tout
seul en allant galoper dans un parc
poussé à la salle salut à tous et la
sainte ou que sais-je
voilà deux ou trois qui conseil
choisissez un sport qui vous plaît et
que vous pourrez tenir sur la longueur
commencé doucement et puis monte
progressivement en puissance pour éviter
de vous dégoûter août vous de laisser
d'ailleurs soyez attentifs à votre corps
et si vous avez mal insisté pas surtout
au début
échauffez vous avant buvez de l'eau
pendant et tirez vous après et adaptez
votre alimentation
ce qui nous amène directement au point
suivant c'est à dire manger plus
sainement ou perdre du poids bon
d'accord ça veut pas dire exactement la
même chose parce que manger plus
sainement
ça peut vouloir dire manger bio par
exemple et ça ça fait pas forcément
perdre du poids les trucs qu'on mange
trop de manière générale et qui sont
mauvais pour la santé notamment pour le
coeur et pour la ligne si c'est ça qui
vous préoccupe le sucre le sel et les
graisses notamment les graisses
d'origine animale d'ailleurs globalement
on mange trop de viande mais bon on va
pas parler de ça aujourd'hui
bon pour diminuer le sucre on voit à peu
près comment faire même si attention
peut y avoir des pièces pour le gras on
croit souvent savoir mais souvent on se
trompe et pourcel on a tendance à croire
qu'il suffit de parts en ajouter dans sa
bouffe mais en vrai c'est pas si simple
d'abord parce que du sel il y en a
naturellement dans plein d'aliments est
d'ailleurs souvent ça suffit pour
couvrir nos besoins journaliers
ensuite parce que comme c'est à la fois
un conservateur est un exhausteur de
goût il y en a plein dans les conserves
et dans les plats préparés cuisiner
soi-même des produits frais c'est mieux
donc pareil si vous voulez faire les
choses comme il faut et tenir la
distance
allez faire un tour chez un médecin
nutritionniste au moins au début et
après par exemple chez lui ni viêt
éthicienne pour qu'on vous fasse des
menus
adapté à l'autre car ça vous évitera de
faire n'importe quoi genre d erreur
contreproductive ou des régimes qui vous
colle des carences que bon bien sûr si
vous vous affamez pendant un mois vous
allez peut-être perdre du poids mais à
ce sera pas bon pour votre santé et 2
l'idée c'est de trouver un régime
alimentaire sain et de le garder
donc les conseils d'un pro ça vous
permet d'avoir un plan de bataille et
une ligne directrice
mais rien ne vous empêche de compléter
sa avec une appli pour vous aider au
quotidien
alors évidemment maintenant tout le
monde connaît tout cas la pluie pour
checker ça bouffe avant de l'acheter
mais il y en a plein d'autres des
gratuites ou des payante qui vous
permettent de composer vos menus de
comptabiliser vos calories de surveiller
vos progrès de surveiller vos erreurs et
c est là encore rendez vous en parle en
faut et puis que ce soit pour perdre un
peu de poids
si vous en ressentez le besoin ou pour
rester en bonne santé
tout passe par l'alimentation l'exercice
physique ça compte aussi ne serait ce
que pour le cardio alors pas besoin de
vous transformer en bête de course un
peu de marche rapide un peu de vélo
c'est déjà pas mal
les règles d'or allez on termine avec
les cinq règles d'or à respecter quelles
que soient les résolutions que vous avez
prises mais si vous avez suivi
vous allez déjà dû opérer une fête vous
aider il n'y a aucune gloire à s'en
sortir tout seul on n'est pas dans un
film the rock
vous risquez de mal vous y prendre et
vous épuisez donc au moins pour démarrer
fait appel à un pro ne soyez pas trop
dur avec vous même être motivé c'est
bien mais si vous vous fixez des
objectifs inatteignables
vous tiendrez pas le coup soyez
raisonnable un petit mil c'est pas la
fin du monde non plus entretenez votre
motivation
rappelez-vous régulièrement pourquoi
vous faites ça et surveillez vos progrès
pour ça les applis c'est pas mal
compensés et récompensé vous d'une
manière ou d'une autre vous allez
renoncer à quelque chose et à quelque
chose que vous associez souvent à un
plaisir donc l'idée c'est de se faire
plaisir mais d'une autre manière
alors d'une manière saine un dû sinon ça
sert à rien après le choix du moyen de
se faire plaisir c'est assez personnel
il y en a qui ont besoin de se défouler
il y en a qui se font des cadeaux il y
en a qui partent en voyage avec l'argent
des clubs qu'ils ont économisé c'est à
vous de voir mais bon ça ne fait pas
tout en même temps c'est très bien si
vous voulez tout remettre nickel au vert
machin etc mais fait les choses dans
l'ordre
commencez par le plus urgent ou plus
logique mais si vous arrêtez tout en
même temps vous allez craquer ou tuer
quelqu'un et ça c'est pas une bonne idée
voilà dtc c'est fini pour aujourd'hui je
vous ai mis tous les liens pour toutes
les rubriques dans la description
j'espère que ça va vous aider n'hésitez
pas à me tenir au courant et à partager
vos bons plans à vous on se retrouve
très vite pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici
là prenez soin de vous et prenez soin
des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]